the award-winning film nowhere to run
was produced by the Yar'Adua foundation
in Abuja an NGO that focuses on social
issues covering the issue of climate
change from a Nigerian perspective was a
key part of the concept there was very
little awareness about it and there was
definitely no policymaking or any
response to what we thought was a global
threat and we thought that if you had a
documentary that it was in people's
faces and told the story of climate
change from a Nigerian perspective that
he would it would have that that impact
of raising raising awareness the film
shows that Nigeria is one of the
countries most affected by climate
change sea levels are rising while lake
chad is shrinking and desertification is
advancing rapidly the title of the film
nowhere to run highlights the fact there
is no escape from the effects of climate
change in this community over 180
children is affected by Google by
inhaling the crude oil no is gas the gas
flaring in Nigeria is the largest single
contributor to co2 in Africa
only natural absorbance to these
greenhouse gases is the plants that is
the forest
the first part of document is very
depressing but then when you get to the
second part where we begin to highlight
the solutions and people begin to see
that you know there's something you
could do and I think that's what gives
us hope is that there is an opportunity
to respond to the threats that we see
solar and wind power combat Nigeria's
energy shortage and at the same time
provide clean energy that helps prevent
further climate change the producers of
the film say their goal is both
education and advocacy I think what has
been most gratifying to me is the
response from Nigerian audiences they've
begun to make the connection between
climate change and what is already
happening in their local communities
everything from desertification to
flooding to rising sea levels to the
shrinking of Lake Chad in Africa the
expected temperature increase is far
above the global average and many
paradises could soon be lost forever
so producing a film about climate change
from an African perspective is crucial